you
all right we have a three check arena no
excuse me
hey created tournament of three check be
the first to give three checks and you
win efore is best buy test in my opinion
look at this fanciness man g3 get out of
my house man get out of my house so was
it worth the time a little fancy Queen H
Queen h4 and then the Queen running back
was it worth it now you're asking for
trouble serious trouble this is already
win it's already a win I got one check
and where's where I only need two two
checks you look up and over tactic I
might have this
we're just taking here
all the way back let's just clear the
way for this night move now I have this
and then this even if they do that here
here check me
here's one check and I kept cream of
that actually
back to turn real and here the Queen h4
idea
I think only has only carries some sting
if you play d4 as a reply or Knight to
f3 because Knight to f3 there's Queen
takes f2 followed up with Bishop c5 and
it's it's tricky for sure so a lot of
the players in this tournament have not
they're still provisional still new
let's let's go with the c5 c5 Knight c6
I'm not afraid of this night going in
here it's not worthwhile to give up a
piece just to give a check but if you if
you can give up only upon and get a
check that's usually worth it
though when playing against a the
stockfish engine it's amazing how you
could give a check to him he'll you'll
give up a pond for it but yeah they
you're hard-pressed to find two more
checks ready to sack on g3 so they gave
one check I should be careful but I have
this extra piece to work with so I'm
ready to to give it right back and
they're way way way down on time yeah
they're just gonna lose on time and now
actually in the three check way they are
losing I go here Bishop takes I have a
check and game over Robert Leeson is in
first okay 29 players that's actually a
bigger crew than I expected for a three
check tournament so here we go
we have some have some theory here this
is the variation I had in mind when I
pointed out inserting a check and giving
up a pond let's do this first netanyahu
that was silly okay let's take care
maybe I should have gone in for this
check they're playing very like a very
theoretical line let's go here
took Queen takes I don't know how I
would defend that pawn successfully yeah
this is this thing they know some theory
I think because this variation is this
one that I've looked at before with the
engine night h6 f5 so now now we have
some some good stuff going this Bishop
is cut out of the action it's rounding
matin three take on h7 rook h3 wreck h8
or h6
and they didn't parry this threat that's
going to do it back to tournament we got
eight still a ton of time left
okay
Robert listen how new is this okay he's
been around but new to the three check
he's up
a good chunk of points 266 this guy here
up for 38
okay Robert Leeson is who we have next a
Scandinavian which is losing by force
actually because of this and then this
and then is it losing by force maybe not
right here's the threat I'll need one
more check to win I just want to get my
king safe
on a stop night to d4 whoo oh I'm
threatening Queen takes Knight now
I got to do this now Scandinavian I
think is a loss by forest believe it or
not and then it's not it's not hard to
believe actually II for d5 give up a
bishop just to give two checks and then
your queen you could basically always
rely upon to give a third and final
check so that turned out to be as a
disaster they gotta take my knight
I think I just want to push this guy I
think this is the right idea to clear
this diagonal and also I have this idea
to jump into this square even if it cost
me a pond yes they give me this h-file
that'd be really nice
still go here I was fearing a Bishop g5
move how many problems I'm down to pawns
all right let's go with this they could
take that pawn
let's take their Knight f3
that is a strong move I guess we're
going to come all the way back
mm-hmm I chewed up a lot of time so far
my king is without a good home rook here
check check I think this works I have a
bishop check and then if King g1 a
bishop check on h2 I check with the
bishop and then the bishop here
and then no matter what we're just going
to go here and then move the bishop next
for me
fish up here I just take that's going to
do it I was even gonna be able to pull
off a fourth and fifth Chuck if needed
that is not needed thou 16-12 eight just
under twenty two remaining 31 and now in
here okay
somebody anybody here we go ah yeah
Sicilians the way to go I think although
maybe a better move order z6 first
they've wasted a lot of time just then
I'll open up my Queens eyes all right
oh oh oh oh I had a check here you dummy
okay we'll go with this check I had
Queen to a5 I was a free check okay
push him I want to get my bishop out so
I'll throw a jab at the knight see where
he goes maybe I take the knight now I'm
definitely taking the knight let's go
here Queen to f6 just get out of any
pins I'm on this guy
that's the only way to defend okay
they could capture that pun
very important you go with the Queen
rook first go on the rook here they they
take with checks so I have a nice Hut
for my king and let's just go here now
good grief I only need two checks rook
here and then here is game over
oh well let's try this they gave me the
F file now we got a second and third
back determine
okay 2016 10 under 20 left
what's up Sherlock one one seven in the
twitch app how are we doing okay
Queen master again I also see Patrick
JMT in the chat hello Patrick JMT all
right so I have a okay there we go
boom we got one check cost upon but I
think that's okay I think it's
worthwhile
alright this this kind of stuff worried
made these up fishing pole ideas they're
pretty serious
pretty serious and
this is scaring me
okay I think I could still do that
afraid of these kind of things pawn
takes knight Knight takes Queen check
but it's only ever two checks let's get
rid of him let's go here Bishop here
there's Knight check I just wanna get
rid of that Knight
let's go here first all right
I already have one check so Queen takes
and then Bishop hears game over careful
making two threat I got to do the other
didn't they didn't defend I always I
always have to end up double-checking I
want to make sure I'm counting right
there have been games that I didn't
count right
and yeah end up giving up my queen and
then things don't end well there right
Knight f3 on move one is certainly
different okay still go for Sicilian
even though that pawn is on III think I
could do this and
can open up this bishop so easily um I
miss playing this
no I don't maybe if the night takes I
have this check I might be willing to
give up my queen for just a minor piece
let's try this
the
I get to recapture and defend here so
I'm just up a clean pond
they had second guesses about taking cuz
they spotted Queen to a5 is my guess
let's just block in case they try to rip
up in the e-file that's Penta and let's
just keep this around so this is this
fishing pole idea I think it's a very
very effective for three check
especially for one minute time to time
control he'd get away with a lot of
stuff so Bishop takes h2 is probably
already an idea and we're gonna go for
it I got the Queen so now chop and then
check is the threat can I still do it
let's just jump in with another piece
careful now
let's go Queen side and how about we go
here and what's the story let's just
push him and we're gonna smash through
right now no time let's check and that's
checkmate back to tournament lions 28
2015 you really have to focus with these
okay okay a little slip 15 and change
halfway point
okay queen master again we're gonna
continue to throw he for out there Queen
h4 not tried this time so we're
revisiting this variation that move
and it take and I believe best here is
Bishop to c7 that's the one that scares
me most that one does not because I just
that's a free check that I just got in
there
no no cost connected with that one night
move I take the bishop with check let's
get rid of this guy
shoo him away
and I guess we'll just step up
okay we'll take here I'm on the bishop
here and we'll go with this just looking
for rook up and over stuff let's back up
let's kick Tom maybe I should have
played Bishop to g3 first there is a
check I don't even like giving this
night Sun check okay here
Queens off are cool with me
and let's win this pawn f3 was an idea
queen exchange I have that I have 1 plus
check and control over the only open
file and a majority here or there just
giving me the rook and that's gonna do
it back to termina 32:23 night that was
a fast pairing to Wade 23 it's a sailing
again
mmm-hmm Bishop to b5
okay so I think what do I think
okay Queen trade let's go here
I want my light-square bishop to play
and I think I think that's okay my king
is on the light square so I like that
and I just want a complete development
which could definitely be a bit tricky I
want to do this I was thinking about
stopping the night but rook to d6 that
activity scared me I think I can get
away with this right now I want to stop
him from eyeing up these gaps
and Castle kingside it's a strong move
there to recapture with my night let's
do this that's not really an
inconvenience rook here I don't have
this because of the check
let's oh I guess here I am really on my
heels really on my heels okay my king
needs to be tucked in much better
yes no maybe here is let's try this oh
they have a winning shot
oh no they had a winning shot rook takes
pawn no matter how I captured I was
going to be in hot hot water hot hot
water not just any water they had a shot
rook takes h6 King takes rook d6 pawn
takes rook d7 that would have hurt I
would have heard definitely I had a
check there that's the first where's the
second let's just get a queen right
there down on time I dodged a bullet
there they didn't see the tactical
shop rook takes h6 that would have stung
my king I what's this this guy is trying
the Queen master variation Queen h4
it's definitely a little bit annoying
these like brute force approaches but I
think I have everything sealed up bishop
before I'm in time to simply castle and
that move I'm gonna Castle h5 is uh
maybe annoying but I can I can start
pushing my opponent around and that's
just encouraging me five that much more
once that move about I could take the
Queen um I'm alright with no we're just
going to do like this I'm not even give
up a single check I'm still getting a
boatload of material that's that's
they're in rough shape after that move
so let's finish this one off as quick as
possible and then here seems like the
way to do it there's one and there's two
and here no matter what
back determine 40:35 still on my heels
here we only played once 40 35 19 10
minutes to go 40 players and all okay
this is a big one
let's try e6 first and what are they
gonna try Bishop to b5 that move take
what the pawn if the knight moves
I forgot the theory on this I think you
go here I forget yeah I forget this is a
really sharp line
I think this is the move Queen to f6 but
I'm not a hundred percent sure this open
Sicilian line is very very tricky
so
I think I think you do know I think you
do this and give up this what am i doing
I'm losing by force I forgot there's
nine to c7
yeah I'm a goner night takes and then
Queen takes here
tried to still pre-move okay we got a
fight and a half 40 39 ouch okay less
than nine hmm what do I have to do in
that variation I'm forgetting what I
have to do in that sharp line after d4
bishop before I know is very tempting
but something's off with Bishop to
Bishop to b4 because of Knight to b5 I
might have to try a different line
altogether if we get paired up again
well it's gonna make it interesting he
has fire hmm okay he's got a fire he's
only one point behind and there's eight
ten to go
okay
I could try to bruiser kiff it comes
down to that but I want to stay away
from berserk let's stay away from
berserk king
you really want to go after a pond
really all this work to go after upon
you know I really hate that that came
did that there was absolutely no fight
in that one I had no chance it was just
direct just a direct kill okay what can
you do they had fish up here I guess
they missed that chop here and then this
is this is a goner' one check I could
deal with there's one check clean here
anything
there we go
determine 40 you know there we go he's
got a lead 44 with fire I'm still at 42
without and if we do get he's paused
he's playing a game though how does that
work
it says pause but he's in a game that's
weird
anyhow let's try you for if we do get
paired I hope I get white such an
advantage playing with the white pieces
I maybe maybe I should be going into
berserk mode I don't feel it necessary
just yet well we'll wait until uh final
few minutes and decide I still think we
would get paired up
and I'm gonna have to win that okay I
have a check but they have a pond okay
let's get rid of that Bishop he's just
too dangerous I have two checks but
that's it
Queen H 294 I could I could deal with
that I'm on the rook and f6
I don't know that I want to take here
though Oh actually that's gonna be
enough
guaranteed second check right around the
corner 44 z-- each he's still in this
game how's it going let me take a quick
peek
they each have two checks he's gonna
lose no he just won okay I think we're
getting paired up here yeah he won that
one and he berserk
he's got five up
now we're not getting paired he still
says paused what's the story with that
all right let's focus on this game I
don't think this is a good one too
berserk playing as black maybe yeah
maybe the white games we could uh we
could go for a berserk five-minute mark
careful bishop still gonna do this Queen
takes pawn I'm gonna give that a go I
get a second check and then a crazy
night getting into g4 they have to stay
and now they're gone her a nice
dangerous back to tournament 4948 he's
in a game the berserk
is he a berserker again no he didn't
preserve that one mm let's see if I get
white this time maybe I try white all
right I tried was drivers ERK four
minutes 43 players
come on pair me up no I got team black
hmm they started out with c3 oh my god
I'm dead
Bishop there see the berserk just
rattles me that's all
they had visit to b5
okay let's just jump on in ooh that's
helpful let's go this way
I'll open up this file
careful
this thing here let's go in for a second
the night has to block I only need one
more check got it back to turn
I left that [ __ ] about for bait 5353
both with fire did Hebrews ark this one
no okay gimme white I'm gonna I'm gonna
berserk this 153 each
come on give me white okay we're going
berserk again ooh ooh you're not
supposed to play e5 Bishop takes pawn
you know and gotta go Knight h6 stuff
okay and now I got mate threats here
knight Knight g5 Queen h5 making two
threat got it and mate next no matter
what easy to miss these long-range moves
back determine okay 5753 is he in a game
he's still in a game how's it looking
it's only got 10 seconds no checks by
either side he might lose that one it's
looking like he's gonna lose go white
go team white okay
[Applause]
I'll try another berserk
I'll try one more berserk this may be
just the last game so let's throw it in
now
I like waiting for that Bishop to move
first castles want to take the knight
out
let's try this actually yeah the rook
move and then Bishop to f4 pawn move if
I take the pawn
okay I could take this and then take the
Queen
fifteen seconds
oh they're giving me everything
they're giving me a lot of stuff I just
want to open it up get my rooks playing
there we go check check and then mate
next
got it 62 yeah they slipped up
are we gonna get paired up again we
might get paired up again but I'm gonna
be able to seal this I got nine points
up now are we even gonna get another
pairing I think once it hits 30 or 28
they wrap things up let's see we got one
more from beginner to master
alright let's just let's just rule that
out altogether
night here okay let's let's go with this
now that Bishop takes Knight isn't
hitting with check just want to push
clear the way for my bishop
I don't know where I want to go with my
king only three seconds left in the
tournament it's not worthwhile to give
up the minor piece for a pawn um let's
go here to be a little bit careful just
a little bit careful take care and we'll
just go here I thought about moving the
Queen but this is
this is good oh that's that's check with
the Queen that's gonna be game over
because of this pawn takes me
or a queen of g2 next they resign okay
we got the I got first place land but
not without a speed bump there how many
games 18 games in there
43 players in all with this one let's
see the pages real quick
it is moving two three four and five
all right it's been a while for the
three check but definitely one of my
favorite variants good games to all 42
of you already
you